[Music]
what's up wisecrack
michael here to tell you that dreams
really do come true
after nearly four years of fans yelling
at studio execs over twitter
warner brothers finally released the
much-hyped snyder cut of justice league
and spoiler
it's big no like really big the film
clocks in at just over four hours aided
of course by a heavy dose of slo-mo
now a few years back we put out a video
analyzing what the original film got
wrong which you can watch
here in it we talk about how the main
conflict of the film was diluted by
character motivations that felt
artificial so instead of getting a movie
about a team of super powered misfits
overcoming their differences to stop the
big bad
we got well this well
i believe in truth but i'm also a big
fan of justice
so how does the snyder cut hold up in
comparison
honestly pretty well sure it's certainly
not perfect and didn't earn universal
acclaim
but there seems to be a pretty
widespread consensus that this once
mythical film righted many of the
originals wrongs
how did it do it let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on zack snyder's
justice league
what went right and the spoilers ahead
but before we get into it i wanted to
take a second to tell you about
wisecrack's movie
podcast show me the meaning it's where
we nerd out about some of our favorite
films from the newest releases to
timeless classics to
the occasional deep cut you may not have
heard of it's hosted by austin
ryan and raymond three guys who would
likely have healthier relationships if
they didn't spend as much time
re-watching john carpenter films to
figure out what they're
really saying but hey their loss is your
gain
episodes drop every other friday and you
can also catch a live stream of every
episode on this very channel so
if for some reason you're not already
subscribed with your notifications
turned on
maybe do that and definitely subscribe
to show me the meaning on apple podcast
spotify stitcher or wherever else you
listen to podcast
and tell them michael sent you for a 10
discount
oh it's it's free well still tell them i
sent you so they know i care about them
now back to the show first a quick recap
now that the man of steel has finally
kicked the kryptonian bucket
these pesky little machines called the
mother boxes think it's finally safe to
reactivate and call home to steppenwolf
once our shark headed villain collects
all three he'll be able to turn earth
into a primordial hellscape and add it
to his master darkseid's collection of
planets
to stop steppenwolf bruce wayne and
diana prince must assemble a plucky band
of heroes
it's got all your favorites including a
brooding aquaman and also brooding
cyborg a socially awkward flash
this is a person who looks exactly like
me but who is definitely not and even
a brief cameo by this brand new floating
green dude
and some they've called me the martian
manhunter of course nothing comes easy
for our ragtag heroes and when
confronted with a literal destroyer of
worlds
the group is left with no choice but to
resurrect superman
which doesn't go off without a few
hiccups he's confused he doesn't know
who he is
but now that the justice league has
their mvp back they decide to take the
fight to steppenwolf with a little help
from some backwards time travel our
group manages to deactivate the mother
boxes and close the portal off the dark
side
oh yeah and wonder woman also cuts a
guy's head off so to see
what went right with the snyder cut
let's compare it apples to apples with
what went
wrong in the theatrical cut and what
went real wrong was something playwright
david edgar calls
dramatic action it works like this any
scene can be boiled down to two basic
components
a project and a contradiction a project
is essentially a character's goal in
that scene and a contradiction is
whatever gets in their way
pretty simple right for example in the
snyder cup we see barry allen applying
for a job at a pet store
only for the best lit hamburger in
cinematic history to get in his way
the project here can be summed up as
barry wants the job
the contradiction is but a car crash
threatens to ruin the interview
importantly having a contradiction
ensures that a scene never ends on the
same note
as it starts and that's what makes
dramatic action well
dramatic barry for example must use his
powers to save a woman from what can
only be described as a
literal sausage fest afterwards he
flashes back to the interview with hot
dogs in his pocket to comfort the scared
puppies
seemingly securing his new job so how
does dramatic action explain why the
original cut of the justice league was
so trash
and how does the snyder cut go about
fixing this well if you parse through
most of the original film
you'll notice a lot of the projects and
contradictions in the key scenes felt
down
right forced oftentimes a character's
project or goal in a scene doesn't
really jive with what we know of them
for example in the original cut there's
a scene where bruce proposes reviving
superman
much to everyone's displeasure bruce no
you have no idea
what kind of power you're dealing with
bruce's goal i.e the project of the
scene
is to convince everyone to bring his new
bestie clark back to life
but this project doesn't really square
with the batman we know so far after all
he just spent an entire movie trying
to kill the man of steel but it's not
just batman who suffers from lazily
constructed projects and contradictions
look at aquaman who spends half the film
not wanting to get involved in a looming
fight
only to completely change his mind over
the course of two minutes
want to know a lazy contradiction having
mera show up for a single scene to drop
some random backstory and conveniently
change his mind
in both these instances it's almost like
the original cut is trying to cram an
entire character arc into a single scene
in the process the film seemingly
botches either the character's
goals or the problems that get in their
way which probably goes a
long way in explaining why the film was
full of lines like this
well i wouldn't count on the tribes of
men we tend to act like the doomsday
clock has a snooze button but i'm
happy to report that the snyder cut is a
different beast entirely unlike the
original this film takes its time to
develop its characters which helps
explain why it's twice
as long as its predecessor as a result
projects and contradictions don't feel
as contrived in this version
let's revisit that aquaman scene again
you might not be shocked to learn that
there was a decent amount of backstory
omitted in the theatrical version
included in that backstory is a scene
with volkow a chief advisor in atlantis
in the scene volcko tells aquaman that
his people are under attack from
steppenwolf but instead of rallying
against a common foe
aquaman's brother the king has been
rallying the troops against insurgents
leaving the motherbox unguarded so
yeah it's a pretty big context go to the
stronghold of atlantis
protect the box the time has come
take up your mother's trident when you
take this impassioned plea into
consideration mera's words this time
around
seem a little less contrived it would
have been her responsibility to follow
that monster to the surface and stop him
now it's yours
but aquaman is only the tip of the
iceberg snyder goes to extra links to
make sure most characters have properly
fleshed out arcs
and he does so without twisting the
projects or contradictions of a scene
to see what i mean let's look at two
characters who feature much more
prominently in the snyder cut
flash and cyborg now as we noted in our
previous justice league video
in the original flash was given a pretty
lame emotional arc that was brought up
and resolved in a single scene
it's really cool you guys seem ready to
do battle and stuff but
full transparency i've never done battle
so project
flash is scared to enter his first fight
and contradiction
batman convinces him it was pretty
underwhelming especially since this
performance anxiety manifests
nowhere else in the film but things are
different with the snyder cut
firstly the film scraps this dialogue
altogether instead opting to show us how
this fear plays out in every battle i
mean seriously
every time barry gets so much as a
scrape he jumps out of the speed force
and gets all teary-eyed but
secondly and most importantly the snyder
cut takes this combat inexperience and
uses it to craft a proper emotional arc
that spans the entire film
one that doesn't need to twist barry's
goals and the obstacles he encounters in
order to make sense
for example look at the film's amazingly
cinematic conclusion
in which barry gets injured at a key
moment as a result the unity is achieved
and life
as we know it ends it's too late pretty
cool
right but barry understandably wants to
stop this so he'll have to run
faster than he's ever run before to
literally turn
back the clock just gotta go faster than
the speed of light far beyond the speed
of light gotta break the rule barry and
you gotta do it now
so the project of this scene can be
summed up as barry needs to stop the
apocalypse
and the contradiction would be but he'll
need to overcome his injury and his own
physical limits to do so importantly
both the project
and the contradiction here feel organic
they also speak to his development as a
character
from scared nerd to real superhero at
this point we've seen barry struggle
with getting hurt as well as his
reservations about approaching the speed
of light i don't like to break this rule
but when i approach the speed of light i
look crazy things happen to time but if
i do it i create massive electrical
power adding the fact that while barry
is attempting to break the very laws of
physics he thinks about how he's making
his father proud and
you've got a genuinely rewarding scene
your kid was one of them dad
[Music]
one of the best of the best but snyder's
four-hour cgi bonanza
isn't content to only give the flash an
arc it also gives some much-needed
screen time to an over-literal
cyborg or victor stone now without
getting into the nitty-gritty about how
joss whedon apparently treated cyborg
actor ray fisher like
garbage it's fair to say that the
original cut didn't have much love for
the character
but the opposite can be said about zack
snyder's version as with the flash we
see the film develop cyborg without
having to twist the projects and
contradictions of each scene
throughout the film we watch viktor
struggle to forgive his father
the man he unjustly blames for his
mother's death
and more justly blames for turning him
into a half-man half-robot
he starts off the film completely
unwilling to listen to any paternal
advice
let me speak to you from my heart not as
a scientist
as a father at the same time he also
hates what he's become
but whatever happened to you you have
gifts now
gives what part of this
looks like a gift to you but after his
dad sacrifices himself to super heat the
mother box
essentially turning it into a thermal
tracking device for the justice league
victor must come to terms with the truth
he loves his father
and he must embrace the hero he's become
in the film's conclusion we see
both of these journeys come to a head as
flash supercharges victor
he must confront the mother boxes and
his own personal demons you don't have
to be alone anymore
we'll be together again the project of
the scene is
victor wants to stop the unity while the
contradiction is
but the mother boxes offer him both his
family and his body back
of course victor doesn't give in to this
temptation a decision which ultimately
saves the day
i'm not broken
and i'm not alone now you might notice
how with both the flash
and cyborg their emotional journey stem
from and directly influence
the plot if barry didn't overcome his
weakness and if victor didn't learn to
accept himself
then darkseid would have added earth to
his collection of planets
and perhaps more than anything else this
interplay between
plot and character was sorely missing in
the original cut
case in point remember the mother box of
men the one held by victor and his
father
in the original cut this mother box was
stolen off screen by steppenwolf while
the rest of the team was getting a
superman
themed beatdown he has the last one and
honestly it was pretty frustrating it
felt like the heroes completely forgot
what they were doing
but in the snyder cut our heroes don't
forget about the motherbox
after jump starting superman the box
lands near victor's dead
then works to protect it with some help
from the team and just when all hope
seems lost
victor's dad valiantly sacrifices
himself so the team can track
steppenwolf to his lair
moments like these where character and
plot move in tandem
are what all cinema strives for and it's
a much welcomed inclusion
of course we're not saying that zack
snyder's justice league is a perfect
film because
it's not in fact it calls to mind one of
the best pieces of advice for writers
and filmmakers alike
kill your darlings that is no matter how
much you personally love a 20-minute
epilogue where the joker makes a
reach-around joke to batman
you won't kill me i'm your best friend
besides who's gonna give you a reach
around you gotta kill it for the sake of
a clear concise story
and it seems like snyder was wholly
unable to trim the fed or even just cut
a sequence of our team walking up the
stairs
do we really need to see that but the
point is the theatrical cut of the movie
tried to do too
much while also cutting crucial
character development and ended up doing
everything poorly snyder left in more
than any other mainstream filmmaker
would dare
and made a seriously interesting albeit
flawed movie
[Music]
and to be honest we think it turned out
cooler than most movies out there anyway
but what do you guys think
is zack snyder's justice league a
shining piece of visionary genius
or is this a master class on why all
good creatives need a time limit
and what do you make of the future of
the dc eu
drop us a line and let us know in the
comments huge thanks to our patrons for
all your support
smash that subscribe button like you're
trying to resurrect a dead superhero and
don't forget to ring that bell
and as always thanks for watching later
[Applause]
the best what best lit best
lit hamburger in cinema history yeah
okay we'll do it